it's an opening night full of fright on
this week Sweetwater secrets
[Music]
welcome back river babes
I'm your host Liana Galera and this is
your Sweetwater secrets after-show for
episode 2 18 chapter xxxi and night to
remember
aka the musical episode now we have so
much musical madness to discuss plus I'm
bringing you exclusive behind-the-scenes
secrets from stars KJ Appa
Madeline Peck and Camilla Mendez so
let's jump right into it with a top
headline of the week in the blue and
gold breakdown now there was plenty of
musical mayhem in this episode but
there's only one headline that you need
to know and that's that the black hood
is back I'm back baby
now during rehearsals for carry the
musical director Kevin started receiving
cryptic messages that were cut from
magazines demanding that share I'll be
removed from the role of Carrie White or
else now for Sheryl safety and because
her mother forbid it
Sheryl was banned from the play and
Kevin recast midge in the role of Carrie
White much to the dismay of Ethel who
clearly wanted the role all along and
even had cut up magazines in her
dressing room
then on opening night the audience was
treated to a killer surprise somebody
should help her that's right poor midge
was stabbed to death and the message
written around her lifeless body read
I'm back from the dead all those who
escaped me before will die and it was
signed from B H aka black hood
yikes it's finally getting good now
let's take a look at what KJ Appa had to
tell me about the black hoods return I
know that the black hood storyline is
coming back because you know I know all
the secrets yes you do you do what do
you think about that I I was over it for
a while but I'm excited because it's
important to our Chi and I would like it
to get wrapped up for him I'm still
maintaining that it's Hal Cooper under
the hood but when you found out that the
black hood storyline was going to be
coming back what was your reaction I saw
it coming that's
are coming for sure it's not just gonna
end like that you know what I mean so
random janitor exactly like who is that
guy I've never made in my life everyone
would've been so disappointed I was
disappointed yeah that's how I knew I
was gonna come back though all right
guys now that the black hood is back
let's break down the list of potential
suspects for who killed Mitch first up
is Fang aka the last person to be seen
talking to midge alive then we have
moose midges boyfriend who was also
Benny really bad mood the night of the
murder then of course there's Ethel mugs
who desperately wanted the role that
midge won and she even had cut-up
magazines in her dressing rooms next two
on the list are sheriff Keller and chick
Cooper because neither of them had any
real reason to be backstage before the
show and lastly how Cooper willed to be
honest I'm only including him on the
list because Hal was there and he bugs
me and I'm really not ready to let go of
my gut feeling that he's been the black
hood from the very beginning
who do you think committed the crime hit
the comments below and tell me but for
now let's put the gruesome murder aside
and focus on the romance news and this
week 7 seconds in heaven now aside from
Cheryl and Toni's sweet flirty eyes and
this epic barchi makeout sesh with a not
so subtle invitation you want us to take
that sexy new Firebird of yours to
Lovers Lane
things were relatively tamed the couples
in Riverdale now while Alice was clearly
feeling hot and bothered after phalluses
trailer rendezvous FP was giving her the
cold shoulder at pops what gives FP one
moment your seductively spitting out gum
and the next year brushing Alice off and
then you're changing your mind and then
you're showing up to the play only to
ultimately bail get it together man
and speaking of disappointing moments I
could practically hear the barchi fans
screams of agony when Betty hijacked
Tommy and Sue's love valid and use the
song is a heartwarming moment for B and
V
is gonna be fine because you shine no
don't get me wrong I loved that B&B made
up I'm just saying I feel badly but the
barchi fans never seem to catch a break
or get a chance to shine even when Betty
and Archie are playing fictional
characters in a play now for more
information from Riverdale showrunner
Roberto aguirre-sacasa on why Betty and
Veronica got that Bart you do it and yfp
is playing games with Alice head over to
ET online for an exclusive tell-all
article I'll also include building hello
now moving on to mrs. and hisses hisses
- Ethel and her ultra salty behavior in
this week's episode sorry you don't have
any M&Ms to wash down that haterade
Ethel but if you were good enough for
the part it would have been yours maybe
try making a better vision board next
time hon wait seriously
hisses - howl for messing up Betty's
plan to make her mom happy you had one
job to do get the right flowers take
note men I'm also sending hisses to hell
for being there an opening night and for
ruining our chances for another phallus
hookup I hate so much about the things
that you choose to be mr. Hiram for
going above and beyond in the douche bag
Department by revealing to Fred that he
actually bought his son a car not cool
hisses - Penelope blossom for killing
Cheryl's dreams of being a star but then
on the flip side with kisses kisses to
Cheryl for shutting down the haters and
proving that she has a sensational voice
and for scaring the hell out of her
heinous mother and demanding her freedom
in fact here's a madelung patch had to
tell me about Cheryl's emancipation
journey moving forward yeah I mean I
think she's always wanted to be
emancipated so it wasn't like a huge
surprise to me but we were at the table
read and we all were like oh like what a
moment like we needed this Cheryl
craziness to pop in at some point it had
been a minute and there it is but I
think more so what was exciting to me
about she's finally stood up to her mom
and it was a huge way yeah because I
feel like it's always been this thing
for her to keep it more under wraps and
then this time she was like I'm done I'm
gonna bring the flames out I'm gonna
bring the blood out and tell my mom
who's boss and it works and I'm gonna
protect Nana ro
tech man arose at all costs at all cost
at all cop man arose his Bey have you
seen her crawl oh my god barber was so
insistent I'm not having a stunt double
for that she's like I'm doing all my own
crawling I was like go for it brother
with your wife she's like I've been
practicing all week she's hilarious Oh
like like give Nana Rose more lines
she's a funniest character and she's
like as funny it's not funny year in
person oh and here's an extra kiss to
Tony for being by Cheryl's side and
giving her all the confidence and
courage she needed kisses to Archie
finally you did something right red
thank you for standing up to Hiram and
from making things right with your dad
kisses to all the musical numbers to
Archie's dancing and an extra kiss to
lily Reinhardt's voice because I thought
she sounded particularly amazing and we
don't get to hear her sing enough this
is kisses to Jughead for his hilarious
videographer moments from keeping an eye
on barchi easy there watch a brother's
watching to has not so subtle spying on
Ethel
oh no he's shooting b-roll I thought he
was perfect in this episode especially
when he looked at Betty this way kiss
has to so many musical makeups first to
Josie for accepting Cheryl's apology for
crushing on her with a little bit too
much force and then to be envy for
finally going from foes to BFFs
kisses to Riverdale for upping the
stakes and bringing back the black hood
so we can get a satisfying reveal that
we all truly deserve and my last kiss
goes to the entire Riverdale cast for
showcasing how incredibly talented they
are in fact Camilla Mendes could not
stop gushing about how proud she was of
her Riverdale co-stars during this
episode take a look it was one of my
favorite episodes to shoot as crazy as
it was putting it together
we had so much fun seeing everybody
exercise these abilities that we don't
always get to exercise I mean I sing and
dance on the show a lot but not
everybody else does and like saying Lily
kind of show off her talents and KJ's is
surprisingly very good dancer even
though he's joking about it he's
actually very good and madellaine sings
everyone just sounds so amazing and I'm
excited for people to see it that was a
lot to jam pack into one episode and
I've still got even mail for you guys
now click the link below to head over to
ET online to read my exclusive
post-mortem article with Riverdale
showrunner Roberto aguirre-sacasa to get
the inside scoop on why Mitch was the
one who needed to die
the latest black hood theories and
what's to come in the next four episodes
now on next week's Sweetwater secrets
preview show for episode 219 chapter
xxxii prisoners I'll be bringing you
exclusive interviews with Camilla Mendez
and Lily Reinhart talking all about B&BS
rekindled friendship plus the real-life
besties spill on their summer vacation
plans now that their roomies together in
LA I'm obsessed with everything that
just happened now as always please give
this video a like and then hit the
comments to tell me your hisses and
kisses about the musical episode who do
you think killed midge and which
remembered alien had the best voice oh
and what are your predictions for what's
ahead tell me everything and until next
time bye bye River babes
[Music]